The Content Browser is an extremely powerful tool for managing all of the content that
you'll find in any of your Unreal Engine 5 projects.
Not only can you use the Content Browser to import content and manage content, you can
also do advanced searches as well as get detailed information about your assets right from within
the Content Browser itself.
So let's go ahead and pop over to the Engine and take a look at this in more detail.
Now to access the Content Browser there's two different ways.
We can come down here and go to the Content drawer which is going to open it up and if
you don't want to keep doing that you can press this dock in layout which is actually
going to dock this right here.
The other way we can do this is by hitting Control Space and that is going to bring up
this Content Browser and the active window that we have.
For now I'm just going to click on this dock in layout so that we can look at this in
a little more detail.
So over here on the left hand side we have our add.
This is where we're going to do things like import or add features or content packs or
add things from Quixel or Fab.
We can also create new folders and then you're going to see a bunch of different things here
for creating basic assets.
Now whenever we want to create something inside of Unreal like a Blueprint or a Material we
do that by either coming here and looking for the appropriate one up here and then create
basic assets or if we need something a little bit more advanced under the Create Advanced
Assets you're going to see a lot of different options down here so what you see is not up
here it's probably down here.
The other way we can do this also is just by right clicking inside of the Content Browser
will access the same menu.
We then have a Favorites which allows us to favorite certain assets that we use quite
a bit and then we have our folder structure that allows us to look at all of the folders
that we have and we can also right click in here and do something like a new folder or
should we want to do something like that.
As we go a little bit further on we have our import which allows us to import save all.
This is going to save everything that you have edited inside of the Content Browser
but it does not save your level so if we want to save our level we click here this saves
the level.
This will save actually all the modified assets.
We then have a little navigation here and this is a menu bar that lets us know where
we're currently at in the folder structure.
Then we have our settings so our settings are pretty cool because they allow us to do
a couple of different things.
First off under the View Type we can change this to things like Lists or Columns and the
cool thing about this is let's just find some stuff here.
When we're at Columns you can see here what I get is a bunch of different information and
this is really cool because this can help me make better decisions about what I am currently
looking at in terms of maybe some optimization.
Here we go if I click on the cloth one I can sort these by my vertices or triangles to
get a better idea of what is going on with them.
I'm going to click this back over to tiles and I'm also going to come over here now
and I want to show you this show engine content.
I'm going to click that on and what that's going to do is you're not going to see anything
really different but we are going to get our engine folder here and you might need to enable
this.
Sometimes if you want to access stuff that's inside of a plugin or maybe you need to access
some content inside of the engine to make something that is always loading or something
like that.
That's how you can actually see that by coming up here again and doing this show engine content.
If not then you won't be able to see that.
A couple of other things to note here.
Thumbnail size, thumbnail edit mode and real time thumbnails.
These are great if you are trying to.
Let me just click back here and go to this right here.
If I go to my thumbnail edit mode I can drag this thumbnail around.
I wasn't on the thumbnail.
There we go.
I can drag this around and move it and then when I'm done here I can just press done editing
and that will save those changes.
If I ever need to adjust this.
Unreal does a really great job of giving you thumbnails automatically so you might not
need to do that but in case you do that option is there.
There is also an extremely powerful search and filter.
I'm just going to reset the filters really quick.
If you want to search we have very powerful so I can do underscore N or let me just click
on the content folder right here and we'll do something like dirt.
There we go.
There's the only dirt that I have right there.
It looks like it's only in the content examples.
One of the other cool things that we can do with the search and I'm just going to paste
this into here is we can make these very complex operands to check for items of certain sizes
or certain properties.
In this example what I'm doing here is I'm looking for triangles less than or equal to
10,500.
Files that are going to have more than 10,500 triangles that's what I'm looking for and
this will spit them all out for me.
The search is extraordinarily powerful.
The other thing is the filter.
If we click on this little arrow right here we get a list of filters.
I generally run with my textures and my static meshes on probably my materials and maybe
my material instances but our filters allow us to filter by whatever we have and then
we can do something like let's look for underscore N, maybe check out all of the normal maps that
we have.
Again, very, very powerful features inside of the content browser and something that
you're going to be utilizing quite a bit inside of your project especially as everything
that you want to import is going to be imported into here and everything that you want to
create in the editor is going to be created from the content browser menu and then utilized
as you need.